welcome back to the second in the series
of order of operations videos so let's
get started with some problems so let's
say I had oh I'm sorry
5 plus 2 times 3 times 5 plus 2 divided
by 2 plus 1 this is a long problem and
if maybe before you saw these videos you
would have been intimidated by this
problem but if we just take it step by
step and keep reminding ourselves about
the order of operations we'll see that
it's pretty easy to simplify down to our
to our answer so what does the order of
operations tells to do first what was
the top priority it was the parenthesis
and do we have any parentheses here well
well yes we do
so right here we have 2 5 plus 2 that's
sitting in a parenthesis so the first
thing we should do is simplify that so
what's 5 plus 2 well that's 7 that's
easy so then we get so then we get I
don't know what my tool all of-a
something looks different but anyway we
get 5 plus 2 times 3 times that what's 5
plus 2 we did the parenthesis first
times 7/2 plus 1 do we have any
parenthesis left no so what do we do
next
we do multiplication or division next
and it actually doesn't matter what
order we do it in we just know that
multiplication multiplication and
division comes ahead of addition and
subtraction so let's do the
multiplication and division first so we
can start at the so let's see all the
places where we have multiplication we
can do 2 times 3 first let me do this in
a different color we could do 2 times 3
first we could do 3 times 7 first or you
can do 7/2 first and I'll leave it up to
you as an exercise to to prove to
yourself it doesn't matter which one of
these we do first
so just to prove that let's start well
it doesn't matter well we could start
with the 2 times 3 just lets us go left
to right that's actually the convention
but it actually doesn't matter so if you
go left from right we get
five plus what's two times three it's 6
times 7 divided by 2 plus 1 right the 2
times 3 just equals 6 that's all we did
I can draw it like this the 2 times 3 is
equal to 7 so now we have 6 times 7
divided by 2 right we do the addition
last so once again we can do it in any
order we want so let's just do left to
right cuz I think that's what the
convention is so it's 5 plus 6 times 7
42 divided by 2 plus 1 and now all we
have left is the division because once
again we do the division before addition
of subtraction
so what's 42 divided by 2 it's 21 so 5
plus 5 plus 21 plus 1 and these are all
the same levels so we could do 5 plus 21
plus 1 or we could do 1 plus 21 plus 5
it doesn't matter but 5 plus 21 is 26
plus 1 is 27 and we are done 27 so that
wasn't too bad and we only had to go 4
steps and we were able to get an answer
out of this fairly complicated
expression let's do another one let's
say I had let me think of a problem 1
plus 2 times 2 plus 1 times 2 plus 1
once again looks kind of complicated but
we'll just break it down with order of
operations we do multiplication first so
let's start with this multiplication
right here 2 times 2 well that's 4 so we
get 1 plus 4 plus 1 times 2 plus 1 we
still have another multiplication in
this expression we have at this one
right here so let's do that 1 times 2 so
we get 1 plus 4 plus 1 times 2 so that's
just 2 plus 1 and now all we have left
is addition so we have 1 plus 4 is 5
plus 2 is 7 plus 1 is 8 now one thing
that I sometimes do to simplify the
order of operations in my mind is I'll
add parentheses that just reinforce with
the order of operations would have told
me
anyway so in this problem I would say
well I'm gonna do the multiplication
first anyway and just to make it clear
in my mind let me pick another color
here just to make it clear in my mind
let me put parentheses around that
without whatever I'm going to do first
and now all of a sudden things start to
look a little bit simpler doesn't it if
I kept those parentheses because what
you do is you look at the expression
immediately and you say okay I'm gonna
do the multiplication first anyway and
just so I don't mess up with the
careless mistake let me put those
parentheses in there to help me read the
problem and once again these parentheses
aren't necessary just the order of
operations alone should tell you to do
the multiplication first but I think
they make it a lot easier to do the
problem without making a careless
mistake let's keep going on so I'm gonna
ask you I guess some may be
thought-provoking questions if I were to
tell you 3 times 2 plus 1 versus 3 times
2 plus 1 with 3 times 2 in parentheses
are these expressions in any way
different well I think if you've worked
it out you'll see that they're the same
and if you think about why are they the
same well in this in this expression we
already know from the order of
operations that we're going to do the
multiplication first
here the parentheses kind of force us to
do the multiplication first but we
would've done at first anyway because
the order of operations put
multiplication ahead of addition so in
this case the parentheses are just
redundant they tell us to do the same
thing right we would've done 3 times 2
is 6 plus 1 which is 7 here we've done
the same thing 3 times 2 is 6 plus 1
which is 7 and once again the press
these are redundant so it tell you the
same thing but like we just saw in the
last example they're actually useful
because they keep they focus you on
making sure you do the multiplication
first and that they in my mind at least
they keep things a little bit cleaner
now is would it have mattered if the
difference was between 3 times 2 plus 1
and 3 times 2 plus 1
well now the parentheses make make a ton
of difference because as we said just
now in this situation we do the
multiplication first and we get the
answer seven but here the parentheses
are forcing us to do the addition first
so when you do the addition first you
get the 2 plus 1 you get 3 times 3 right
2 plus 1 is 3 and you get 9 so you get a
different answer so in this case the
parentheses matter so if you think about
it the parentheses really matter when
they force you to do something lower on
the ladder in the order of operations
before you do something higher on the
ladder hopefully that helps and I just
encourage you to keep doing a lot a lot
a lot of practice and really I mean
almost every math problem you ever do in
your life you're gonna have to do order
of operations on some level so it's very
important that you understand this well
now have fun